welcome thank you so much
so excited for this i am too
hell yeah
it's been so fun being here with you
guys
yeah
it's been fun having you
for those of uh
our audience
that
um are wondering
like what we're talking about
um
so i'm currently in the netherlands uh
working with bentino and the team
and
uh have been here since august
so we're on our fourth month
yeah
and
this was all after i attended the costa
rica retreat in march and started
getting more excited about
igniting global awakening the mission
and
cory's been
how many years now seven years since you
met ben i think so seven yeah yeah
cool since 2014.
it's 2015 actually early 2015. pretty
yeah so pretty much approaching seven
cool and that was back in
boulder mm-hmm yeah
cool
those videos of you are so funny the
conscious class ones or whatever just
the ones of you sitting with ben like
talking to him uh oh
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah because that's
like you when you were 23. yeah yeah
i remember the first thing i
the first time i like raised my hand in
a session and asked him a question
he was like talking about how everything
physical is a manifestation of something
and i was like
i saw you have some zits
like what's that and he remembered that
he's like wow like the first thing you
say to me
you call me out in public for myself
yeah
yeah been a while
nice
nice yeah what
thought is creating visits yeah
nice
yeah so now you've had so many years of
picking up
like these patterns of the way that
consciousness expresses itself
and
sort of
like seeing the difference between
um
when someone is coming from a place of
like knowledge of the nature of reality
and of non-separation and of
um
enough service um versus when somebody
is uh coming from um ignorance of of um
unity
um and then just like seeing all those
different patterns of expression of
of uh how to like shift like that was
the theme of the event in in march was
the shift into permanent alignment so
it's like shifting into realizations
shifting into awakening shifting into
service
um
and it's a really subtle art is sort of
helping um
guide
people when they ask for oh how how do i
become more realized or how do i
dissolve these bits of separation how do
i serve people better so yeah so in this
last um
like
seven years now or so of
of of you know becoming more of like a
jedi at this
um
you and i sort of went through uh
like the last couple of weeks you know
you were stressing
to me you were um mentioning to me quite
a bit like hey go on the offense like go
on offense like look at
you know what is those what are those
bits of separation what where are you
still
um
where are you still feeling um
like seeking validation or still um
wanting to be seen or
um
having like sabotage style agendas to be
seen um things like that
and
i think that that's been really
insightful because i've spent so much of
my time going up into concept land and
into the
metaphysical clouds and it's been great
um but then this next level has been
very much like human
um it's been very much like well where
are those shadowy aspects of my
expression of consciousness yeah
so
i think that's a good place for us to
start is um just maybe you sharing with
us um what's been your
um both your experience with um the
shadowy side of realization and then how
that serves the awakening but then also
seeing the pattern in in people say the
first part again so my experience with
the shadowy side of realization yeah
yourself and then also in the
expressions of of the patterns for other
people and how that serves them when
they see those shadowy aspects how that
serves their awakening
yeah cool really cool question
um
well i i would say it's sort of the
the main
like when we say like do the work this
is
the main work
it's like looking at the shadow stuff
it's and shadow is a little bit of a
misnomer or something like it has all
kinds of connotations
um
but it's like yeah where am i
trying to get or consume or position
myself or
um
i mean i guess i like most the context
of service to self for service to others
and when you're truly of service to
others i mean this is essentially like
in buddhism there's like the three paths
i'm going to totally botch this
um but there's like
concentration do you know the three
concentration something else and i think
wisdom
and wisdom is like the never-ending path
of self-refinement
so like you can have realizations cool
wonderful you can have and there's
another path i forget and then um
but then there's this wisdom i'm not
sure if that's the word but it's like
the con the never-ending
path of like can i be more of service
can i be more loving can i radiate more
can i
purify this vessel even more
cool and i mean that's to me what
inspires me so much about bentino more
so than his realizations because he's
had realizations that i haven't so it's
hard for me to
to even know what's special about that
um but the but the purification and the
work that he's done on himself is what
is so impressive to me
and it's what we do here that's what
you've been getting a taste of
yep
so for me
man it's like
it's um
it never ends it really is a
never-ending path of of
self-refinement and purification but i
can think of tons of examples
of when i was doing something that felt
innocent
me see if i can get a good one
it always feels innocent at the time it
always feels it's always kind of a blind
spot it's just a behavior it's just a
mode it's just uh you know it's your
personality
um and then when it gets addressed or
reflected or called out
you realize that it wasn't it's not you
it's
a strategy it's a strategy to get
something yeah and that's sort of that
peeling the sticker off of the sticker
paper and like realizing like damn this
whole
this whole thing that i thought was me
is not and it was and it's this like
this hitchhiker in the back of my car
that's trying to get whatever gets some
sort of validation
so there's one story that's coming to
mind but i always tell this story so i'm
trying to think of a have you shared it
online before the story
maybe not
i mean i've shared it in boot camps and
stuff
um
oh but there's been so many there's in
it's hundreds you know what i mean it's
there's hundreds of layers of
self-deception yeah
thousands i mean it's
tons it's time so when you and when you
start when you start going in there
you you get humbled by how much how much
more there is
um so anyway so this was back in egypt a
few years ago
five years ago or so
and
i asked we were in a group and i was a
little bored with how the group was
going like we needed to up level
and so i asked bentino for a reflection
or i just asked him to like can we up
level this and he said you want a
reflection
um and immediately it was my first
thought was like
[ __ ] this like i don't need this like
immediately i felt the confrontation of
it immediately i felt the like exposure
yeah i was like [ __ ] i don't need this
in front of 20 people like for you to
give me some sort of
and which isn't that amazing to go on
the defense immediately when i want an
up level but to immediately get
defensive
and i think that's what everyone does
it's kind of it's our programming it's
like you want to you want to procure
your innocence you want proof of your
innocence you don't want proof of how
you've been a saboteur or how you've
been you're not looking for that
um and so i said yeah
begrudgingly
and
um
and he said
all right tell me about your laugh
your life and i was like oh what yeah
i'll tell you about my laugh
and um
and so we got to a place where i saw
that often and this kind of came from
like high school like
you know trying to be cool being with
the popular girls conditioning
um where i would use my laugh like i
would just like
i would clear i'd make it so clear to
people that wherever i was was the cool
place to be the fun place we're laughing
here oh we're excited over here
so and like and that was one of my
mechanisms like i would
just have this like field of like
this is the place to be
i'm
it's so fun over here just to kind of
have the attention just to get the
validation
um
it was so cool this was like a two hour
process of me just resisting it
resisting it not wanting to see it but
still like still being like i'm gonna
get this like still having enough
curiosity or enough humility or
enough willingness to
pursue it despite how uncomfortable it
was
um
and then that was like that was one of
those bombs that once you get that like
how you've you've had a few of these
like once you get that thing that just
it's like
it's like the domino effect of just like
oh my god everything i've been doing is
full of [ __ ] everything it's like my
whole personality this whole construct
is to get validation to look good to
have people's eyes you know
seeing me positively favorably
um and i remember just for like about a
week just like every every single thing
i did
was repulsive to me like i couldn't make
eye contact without
being like damn even in my silent eye
contact with you i'm trying to get
something out of you even even in this
text the way i'm framing this text i'm
trying to get something out of you just
to see everything everything i was doing
was a manipulation everything was
strategic to get something for myself
and completely
completely ignorant of what was best for
that person there you go yeah
so
uh so cool yeah
that's such a good one yeah
yeah like the subtlety of just the laugh
um
to get eyeballs uh this is the place to
be like i'm the person to talk to mm-hmm
yeah uh for me it shows up as i'm i'm
awake like look at me look at how woke i
am
yeah
um
yeah cool okay so that that's a good one
and then that also like you said
unraveled a bunch of
but sometimes it takes a while to
sort of
like surrender to the reflection in a
sense because you have that we have the
defense of that self-preservation
mechanism that's wanting to refute um
the reflection
but the best thing we can do is go on
the offense like you said like i want
this like i want to learn about this um
i want to see through it's important to
see where you identify so what everyone
does almost everyone does is
if i'm going to give you a reflection
it's you're it's personal it's like
because you are identified with the
reflection so when bentino said tell me
about your laugh or what even when he
said want me to give you a reflection it
was like no
like me
it's me like i'm identified with
whatever thing so if but if if i had
known in retrospect and this is
something that i know now
that a reflection is necessarily not me
that anything that could be
impure or off or misaligned or
malintent or manipulative if we can find
that i want to find that i want that off
like that's a barnacle that's like a
that's a that's a glasses that i don't
want to be wearing and if somebody else
can help me see those i'm going to go on
their team and look for those same
glasses
like game on well let's find those
so but at the time and what everybody
does it's it's personal it's like i'm
identified with all of this
so if you're going to call me out that's
personal that's you're you're
threatening me and so that's why we get
that sort of like defense mode but if
you just go on the offense and look for
it too like you see something yeah well
help me say it let's find it that's cool
yeah
wow
yeah okay so i love that last bit so
um
so to start with how it
uh
asking for to because like you said
there is like it's like a lens of
perception that you don't want to be
wearing anymore
um or it's like it's not you the
reflection that's coming is not you so
you want help to sort of look for how
i'm expressing myself that's in a
twisted way manipulative way trying to
extract or get validation these type of
thing and then
when you sort of see it that way and you
see it as sort of oneness helping itself
see that see through that nice way to
put it i like that yeah cool
yeah guards down so it's like if your
if our intention is to purify
and maybe nice to explain that
purification is
um
like peeling off all the not you
basically all the all the conditioning
all the everything that's like i'm just
the kind of person who doesn't like
singing or anything that's just like i'm
just like anything that is like uh
this is who i am this is what i am this
is how i operate this is what i think
this is anything like that anything that
is is inherently limiting it's just
taking that off so if that's actually
the intention if purification is
actually the intention
um
letting your guard down to people who
can see
blind spots is like the most efficient
way you can purify yes
and teaming up with them would be even
bonus yeah bonus
for sure yeah speed things up yeah
totally yeah yeah because those patterns
can't survive in a high intensity
environment
yeah
so when you're there every day
it's uh
every single expression
that you have is being
looked at and yeah you know this first
hand
[Laughter]
oh
yeah this is good this is great i i love
where this is going i feel like this is
um
this will be a good place for us though
um
to investigate continue playing on for
um for a bit on this on this episode
together cool
okay
so
another way that's helped for me to
see this is that
it's
you know from
spaciousness or from consciousness
itself is then atlas or corey or
whatever character
and then the expression that that
character has and so
to sort of see yourself as like that
that empty cognizing conscious space
and then to see that then you have this
character appear and then you have these
patterns of expression up here of that
character
and then
you're really um
it really it kind of it makes it so that
the way that this
that the character expresses itself like
you you told me this uh a couple weeks
ago and i thought it was so good that
it's like
creating your own like deconstruction
project um of your personality of all
those patterns so it's like a
it's like a simulation for you to uh
deconstruct your psychology um your
patterns of expression and so when you
treat it that way it becomes like a game
um yeah it's like like get experience
points by liberating yourself from the
conditioned patterns where you seek
hits of validation um or
where yeah where you um
yeah we're like watching where where
every word is is coming from um at that
level of
awareness and
and intent
yeah and then so so i i like seeing it
that way because i feel like then
especially for
um like in the age of technology that
we're in it feels like people are
becoming more aware of like patterns
and um
and
like being able to see themselves as a
deconstruction project i just i feel
like that's really um helpful and so
then you do want you do want
um
oneness to help itself see those
twisted or distorted patterns and then
to liberate itself from that and you can
achieve that much faster by surrounding
yourself with people that have seen
those patterns so that's where i was
also getting at earlier by you being
here for seven years you're basically
picking up
um all of those subtle patterns and then
you're able to
um
help people in all of those different
ways liberate themselves from
conditioning and
i love that i love that so much it's
probably one of the most exciting things
for me is immediately after
i turn
inward and investigate and deconstruct
and liberate myself from a pattern
then i kind of become a steward or a
shepherd for being able to help serve
people liberate themselves from that
pattern nice yeah
yeah i feel like that'd be a good place
also for you to
speak on is now that you've seen like
years and years of different patterns of
um of all these like lack beliefs
showing up in people's expression
and then now you are also becoming more
aware of okay well this they're like
different flavors or different on the
color palette and then now you can sort
of like become aware of the best ways to
help people deconstruct those
and then um so yeah so let's let's talk
about that cool i wonder if there's um
because for sure first thing that comes
to mind is like that is just tacit
knowledge that's just like
you you just learn by doing yeah and
it's a little hard to be like well if
x then why
it's unworthy
actually i've had a little bit of a like
fantasy of one day making some sort of
like resource book like you know those
books you can like flip to the tab it's
like uh-huh here's me follow the is this
then this like
and like get to the result pray
um
yeah so but you're right you're totally
right like it sort of accumulates over
time
um
maybe not over time but over experience
with a bunch of different people a bunch
of different processes seeing what works
i'm still man every time i see someone
have a breakthrough it's like
what caused that like what was it like
what landed for them and it's i love
you're you're really um
with yours you've been super
like verbal about everything so it's so
cool because it's like you it's just
like here's what happened here's what
clicked here's the thing that romeo said
that landed here's the thing that corey
said that landed here yeah and so it's
like oh damn that's awesome feedback for
us cool um
because
in a way these things just seem to take
time it's just like
uh all right you can sense
somebody has a handful of distortions
it's never it's never like ah here it is
i know exactly it's never that it's just
like let's
feel it out let's see something's gonna
cross a line and then we're gonna be
able to be like haha like let's look at
this here we go let's let's let's begin
and we don't even know what the lines
are necessarily
um
and it doesn't have to be that they
cross a line it can just be that they're
frustrated or um
or they just stick out too much like
stick out like a sore thumb from like
the harmonious frequency of the group
and then there's something that's like
oh you're trying to you're doing too
much you're trying to get something for
yourself it's it's disruptive it's it's
disrupting the innocence in a way of the
group so it's like something has to
um
like peak the radar and then once it
does there's permission or there's an
invitation to sort of go in and start
navigating with them and reflecting and
but man if i were to try to like paint a
picture of
it is just
it is just tacit knowledge
um
but there's patterns that's one thing
that's been cool
that you can uh
there's not too many
new things like there's not too many
different
like i would guess there's like
it's just a random guess but i would
guess there's like 30
sort of
personal
process archetypes or blueprints and you
can sort of map any new process to one
of those yep
so
yeah it doesn't feel like like there's a
ton of new i mean it's rare that it'll
be like whoa i've never seen a process
like this or i have no clue how this
person can
can break through or
or sort of transcend this layer of yeah
so it's not too common that it's just a
total
totally new
situation
how's that
is that online with your question yeah
because it's like practicing a sport or
a musical instrument
so the classical analogies of you know
you will over time you use the word
tacit yeah tacit yeah interesting um
like experiential
i'm not sure i think what tacit
knowledge as sort of like a concept
means is um
it's like it's like when people refer to
a workplace you want employees with
tacit knowledge with which is just
people that have been there and like
know their roles yeah they've just like
done it a lot so they
you can say like
how do you do this and they wouldn't
even be able to tell you they just
oh no they just
yeah so it's not like you can't say like
here's the job description you have to
it's just like no you there's no way to
really
quantify tacit knowledge yeah
yeah nice okay yeah
yeah that that definitely resonates um
okay
okay so
so the contrast that we want to
um
share is that the
and you mentioned this earlier too that
you have this
what you could call a polarity between
service to self and service to others
and so then you can like begin noticing
in your speech like communication is one
of the best ways to begin noticing um
am i saying this for myself or am i
saying this for
serving for serving other people
and then
um
and then so within this like tacit
knowledge of serving other people
um
well probably one of my favorite
examples of this right now which is
really relatable to um what we're doing
with no limit society you guys can find
the link in the bio below it's been in
the bio of most of our recent interview
content
um
this is uh training free agents for the
ignition of global awakening
and 10 out of 10 recommend 10 out of 10.
it's so cool it's so cool we have these
awesome uh sessions on wednesdays that
are like three three hours long of i'm
covering different subjects like
self-realization
or some of these like shadow um
or like gremlin or hitchhiker aspects
and like liberating ourselves from those
patterns
um
but a lot of other cool aspects which is
like the catas which is what i want to
talk about
so we have um these groups of uh
like 15 or 20 people that are then
um kind of shepherded in their own um
realization and liberation from patterns
of conditioning by somebody that's kind
of been there at least a little bit
right so like corey you could say
someone that's been there quite a bit or
me somewhere that's sort of starting to
be there and starting to serve and so
um
it's been really interesting being in a
position where
i'm really the whole time when i'm on
the cater call is i'm just actively
listening to what they're saying and
then i'm
and then i'm just like just naturally
really just the reply is about them and
the reply is about you know where
they're at and the replies about how
what can serve them what can help them
liberate themselves from some sort of a
pattern or to
help them
realize at a deeper level what their
true nature is just things like this
and
so then so then you begin sort of
carrying that with you everywhere you go
um that style of behavior expression
so
so okay so then
i would say probably you gave 30 example
you you said there might be like 30 of
these different ways to like deconstruct
psychology like different ways that
psychology even builds up or identity
builds up let's say
um
because if it doesn't even build up if
separation or conditioning doesn't even
build up then you're like
you're just a kid that becomes like an
awake teenager or whatever um because
you have awake parents perhaps or this
type of thing
so then
if there is this um construction project
of identity and separation conditioning
that happens then there are also and
typically it happens in
let's say that
one of the ways is sort of like
people feeling unworthy and then seeking
getting worthiness from other people
yeah um that's a pretty common one i
would say yeah
so like people speak
um so that they can be validated by
other people yeah um i would say
unworthiness is
like either the one that's at the root
of all of them or it's like one of three
that's at the root of all of them it's
like it's it's one of the most common
things so i would say that even these 30
things this is so speculative but
even those 30 things those start after
the unworthiness lack belief so these
are sort of like the ways it manifests
that i'm yeah talking about the
construction project sweet sweet sweet
and then you could even say that even
deeper than unworthiness is even a
feeling of separation nice yeah
beautiful yeah okay sweet and then even
before that a feeling of location
location yeah that's cool
nice location separation unworthiness
and then it
yeah definitely like blossoms or um
or like uh expresses itself in
uh varying waste from that source point
you could say location separation it
shows up as unworthiness or whatever
else
um
and then now then you have the other way
of viewing that which is so there's the
construction side of it
and then there's the deconstruct
side of it which is where you get people
um like courier like some of the other
kaita guides in the limit society that
have sort of seen some of the patterns
of how to they've been there done that
this tact
knowledge
t-a-c i-t i-t yeah test it this tacit
knowledge so i've been there done that
on the deconstruction side of it and
then now
um
well maybe this would be a good place to
ask you what have you seen in terms of
most common ways of deconstructing
because we mentioned it a little bit
like actively listening like feeling
into how to ask a good question that
would help somebody have insight
into their conditioning
interesting there's um
there's like layers to it so at the very
very outside
um
i mean at the very outside layer it
could just be like
little seeds planted in movies or little
it's just like things that have you just
like huh
like that have you sort of changed your
framework a little bit or you know just
little so
so sort of at the most diffused
end of the spectrum it can just be like
little planted seeds
um
and
it's it's not effortless to get
toward the center
so to the center it's where like you are
signed up it's like i would say that i'm
close to the center of like i have
signed up if i do anything in pure it's
going to get reflected immediately
if there's an ounce of uh sort of
self-gratification in my behavior i have
no wiggle room no so it's like an
immediate
like mark's been great at that for me
recently nice good yeah yeah so like
where we are it's like the
um
remind me of your question again so i
don't the deconstruction the
deconstruction process yeah and patterns
of that and how shepherding works with
that
uh cool you asked me something when us
why was that oh and you went to the
onion layers yeah yeah um
and it's not effortless to
so
okay because you were talking about how
you'll sort of you'll do like active
listening cool to me that's kind of like
a mid-range thing like yeah just like
listening to people offering some tips
some like maybe consider it like this or
have you you know so that's kind of more
like
safe and not too confronting people can
take it or leave it yeah nice oh i like
where you're going with this right sweet
and so but then there's a certain
threshold
um
where you
where
it's the wrong
word but there's almost like a
transaction it's like a
all right all right i'm in
like i'm in for this work i'm in for
this heat and it can i mean there has to
be some sort of
um
for you for us it's been
like all right i want to be on this team
like i want to work with you guys i want
to i want to
be a shepherd of this content like i
want to make sure that the team works
well and people are taking care of and
the stuff and and like the
the material is handled so there's
actually responsibility here so then our
um
our process suddenly becomes everybody's
business there's no private space in
that once you're like all right i
volunteer i'm in i sign up for this i
choose me like let's go
i enter the heat like enter the ring of
fire now
you don't get the luxury of take it or
leave it it's like if you want to be in
oh yeah your stuff is everybody's
business and now the heat is on yeah and
so if you've got some stuff coming up if
you've got some um
if you're strategizing if you're
positioning yourself if you're competing
with other people on the team if you're
withdrawing if you're insecure that's
our business like we can't have that
it's a liability it's a
it messes with the team no
and it's not just the team i use that
example because it's mine
but there can be any sort of any sort of
environment where you just opt in for
the work or for the reflections or to
see the blind spots or to transmute the
ego or whatever in modality or whatever
and when you there is
a threshold that when you cross
um
it's like you're on the hook
like you're accountable now it's not
just
seeds planted and
and gradual progress and reading it
reading a really nice self-help book
so there's sort of a different
um
yeah and there's probably more more
nuance to the gradient to the spectrum
but
uh yeah and your question was about then
once
so this is cool cool um because you
we could say that the construction
project is sort of the forming of the
onion layers and the deconstructions the
taking peeling away of the onion layers
and that when you sort of start at the
edge of the onion is where you get like
sort of the safe ways of
help serving where you maybe ask a
clarifying question or have you seen it
this way that kind of thing
i'm still definitely playing it safely
that's so good actually though and i
think you i think you don't only play it
safe like you get in there you get in
the yeah in the ring i do i do but um
i'm still sort of figuring out how to
um
come from a confident um place that's
also
humbly like a shepherd there
rather than uh also coming from being
seen at the same time okay this actually
made me think of an important
distinction so i think there's a
conception that if you like join the
team you're like in that you're on like
an nba team so now it's you
like the heat is time people are calling
each other out and it's you know like
like high intensity and it's not
necessarily like that it's super
harmonious actually
um
so
leadership by example i would say is the
most effective yeah the single most
effective thing because that's
that's what has people like
pay attention totally it's like if
you're embodying it yes if you're
embodying purity that's what has people
be like i want that yes so then you're
you can just say like sorry
what's up are you okay and that'll just
like send ripples through somebody's
process like oh my god i'm not okay i've
been you know you can if you're actually
embodied if you're actually cool you can
just ask a you can ask a clarifying
question no heat at all with the
question like that it was just super
soft and gentle yeah
or it can just be an eye contact or it
can be an uh a not responding to a text
or it can be the gentlest of the gentle
and um
and have an incredible effect because
you've got you're leading by example
because you've sort of
you're an example of it you uh an
embodiment yeah of it
so
cool yeah so that's been an interesting
process too to see like that it's
actually less there's kind of like this
illusion of more and more heat and it is
you're more and more accountable but the
heat isn't
it's like it's kind of hotter
on like one of the outer rings a little
bit more it's like a heart like where
people are more like there's more
friction people are sort of trying to
like
get honest and admit stuff and they have
you know it's like there's this um
build up of
whatever suppression people have so it's
like finally they want to
like rip the band-aids off and reflect
everything and admit everything and like
go through all of their vulnerabilities
and call people out for the subtlest
things and so that's a phase
that i think a lot of people are in
right now i think in the catas it's a
good place for people to to practice
that just to sort of like i don't know
whatever it is just get there
just get this burden off their shoulders
but after that after that and after it
gets um
even sort of closer to the core it calms
down a lot
i mean the sensitivity is even higher so
the smallest things
make an enormous difference
um but it's not it's not so loud it's
not so it's not like
this intimidating intense atmosphere i
don't know maybe you can
you can uh i'd be curious how that
resonates for your experience yeah
that's cool
um i love the example that you gave of
just
the embodiment of of purity and
and oneness and service to where it's
just as simple as
hey like how you doing
it's like oh god
bullshitting right now i just saw it
through your eyes yeah exactly nice yeah
like that
that's so cool so cool um
yeah because
there's almost uh there's like you can
hold eye contact from that place longer
and then the person like feels that and
they're like oh i'm not that right now
there you go nice like that yes um
oh it's so good so good so rich right
now so okay
okay so i feel like
i i feel like i want to stay there for
another second because it's just such a
good point
um
like when you look
um
you're seeing the spaciousness like
you're seeing
like the truest deepest nature of
infinity of consciousness and you're not
seeing a person construct that's
unworthy trying to get things that type
of thing nice actually i like i like
where you're going with this
um
yeah so to be in an environment and i
people
experience this all the time coming here
where it's just coming into this
environment
and not having the comfort of
um
messy social
places to hide yeah it's like where
people aren't projecting and people
aren't
just
regurgitating [ __ ] and yeah and
you're actually here where people are
like hi
yeah hello hello what's up yeah
like with no momentum
um it's super exposing it's you become
so aware of everything that comes up
like
holy [ __ ] like it's i'm pure programming
like just it's like all the conditioning
is just like
yeah it's excruciating it's like those
that week that i had in egypt after i
had this this like oh my god everything
i do is manipulative
everything i do is so that is super
confronting often when people come to
this so i like i like uh
where you're taking this with if if
you've embodied it you have that effect
on people bentino has that effect on
people people are so intimidated yeah
it's like immediately just coming he's
like oh my god patina's here
and just immediately they're aware of
everything
and this is one of the i would say the
coolest aspects to
um enlightenment or awakening or
um that spaciousness is that
it's uh it's really visceral it's really
embodied um and it's really just present
and like the radiance of of um
and
and then it's uh like you said when
you're with that in proximity um
whatever your
um
however you're not like that is revealed
yeah to you
um
and that's where you can sort of use
words like mirror
um
and it's it's really cool
to to tune into what that's like
to
well
not only to
um
to empty
myself or oneself of so much of the
self-interest
that it is just that mirror like
spaciousness and service
but also to then be also in proximity to
those that are already that
clearly and then to see
to be like to be really aware of of uh
of that and
because like i also get to see it
through
through you and through uh ari cars
remain mark etc
because you guys have spent years and
years also
with ben and on this process of seeing
these subtleties of consciousness and
the way
we express ourselves and then
so then it it is like it really do i
mean the analogy is so good it does
really this like onion-like analogy of
then
knowing how um the optimal ways of
uh
deconstructing the the onion layers
themselves over time you just
taste it it becomes tacit
knowledge of how to optimally serve
um
in that deconstruction
this is that this is great i feel like
um
that covers a lot of what i wanted to
touch on i i have another point that i
want to touch on so
um
a lot of the times when we talk we talk
about things like um vibration
um
or frequency and i think that's uh one
of the best ways that we can possibly
put like the way that we express
ourselves um and so are you you know
expressing yourself at
a
um
a place of a lot of separation and
identity and
unworthiness or are you expressing
yourself from a pure empty place that's
just there in service
and
and maybe that's a
maybe that's a good way for you to
to share do you feel like the tacit
knowledge has become mostly then you
could say vibrational it's become more
like um
like a sensing
in a sense like you're still
and then that
enables you to sort of see
more clearly
the vibration of where other people are
coming from if they're coming from a
place
that's like the unwinding of like you
said there's no places for you to go
here for you to be able to
just
have mundane
conversation anymore um
and then
you see you see that style of vibration
expression and then you see the other
style which is maybe another person
that's quite still
that's quite there
happy
relaxed like just waiting to like oh
like someone came and sat down and they
want to have a conversation
and then just kind of like tuning in to
them
so do you see it sort of vibrationally
you see it like are you still
and then you see the vibrational
expression
of others
in detecting benefit where you can serve
that type of thing
um even this is part of the tacit
knowledge so i think you're right i
think it is just vibrational and i think
it does come from
sort of whatever level of stillness or
um
like quietness that i've reached
up to that level i can perceive it in
others i guess and more because i can
perceive people who are sort of more
advanced than me
um
um
yeah so
in a way it is there's kind of like a
radar like a little satellite or of just
like where is
um
yeah it is vibrational
because it's just like harmony harmony
harmony oneness when this one this like
alignment alignment and then you just
notice when something's like needs a
little like
you good
or um
or a conversation or or even in
conversation when
i sit down with somebody
on the team and we just kind of lock in
and connect and just like what's up
and it's like there's something that
could use a little clarity or something
that could use and that's where we'll go
like so we sort of follow the
um
so interesting i think that is um
when ben talks about being available
or
um you just said something like that
like
being attentive to
the highest benefit
of it yeah um i think that's the
mechanism in a nutshell it's sort of
like this little like radar that's just
like
and then you can i mean we
we all love to just like shoot the [ __ ]
and like yeah be ridiculous so
it's not that the only behavior that we
that we enact is like detecting the
highest benefit it can totally just be
fun random silly stupid
nothingness
um but yeah like if that's sort of the
if we're like in a group setting and i'm
kind of like walking and gauging like
where am i where will i sit or where
will i go and address or
what will i
pour my
um
what will i pour my attention into
that's what i'm
it's like where do i sort of feel like
something could use a little
light
yeah
so you used radar which i liked so
so it'd be like rather than
being only focused on yourself
um
you
[Music]
try to
expand your uh area of focus like beyond
what you can extract or like get
yeah good point to then more people
um as like over time like
expand
yourself
um
to you know a room of people if you can
up to the whole universe and
when you
um
sort of see like on the radar are you
seeing um
where you can come and
give attention to the hole that then
brings a little bit more light into
where somebody could feel contracted or
still separate
or be perpetuating a pattern of
conditioning that type of thing
that
i like the radar and i like how you said
earlier also this like the ping
like
uh nature as well so
um
when you get to these levels of
sensitivity where you can sort of
you know you can feel like beep like and
then like oh over here that's what it is
or
um
i think you made the most important
point which is
if and when i'm not
consumed by whatever my own thing
so yeah there you go and that's sort of
the main i think that's the like human
condition for the most part is like
people just like walk into a room like
aware of themselves yes just walk into a
room
and kind of want to connect but it's
there's so much agenda like there's so
much intention to get
validation or or even or even to like
have an effect and to be the one that
caused that effect
um that's a probably a pattern of mine
cool yeah to be the one to be the one
that does yes yeah totally and it's
subtle
and what i would recommend for people is
to not be like do i have that or not
it's like no just
assume you do duh you definitely do not
just like gauge what it is
so look for what it is like what's your
hidden agenda when you walk into a group
or a nice engineering room that you do
for sure
it would be totally it would be totally
full of [ __ ] too yeah so start with
assuming that you have a pattern that
you're not aware of yeah that's great
that's a great first step
yeah
funny huh because it's so obvious but
it's it is necessary to say that
because even that
um
opens that creates just enough opening
for you to begin digging yeah deeper
because if you don't say that first
thing there's no opening do i have any
uh inauthenticities do i have any hidden
agenda socially nope no
as opposed to like all right where
like where is it like what am i how did
i get something from myself out of that
last interaction why did i say that
why did i really say that not just no
because i was curious about where she
got that shirt no like why did you say
that like why what did you get what was
the
what was the potential that you could
have gotten at it out of her being
complimented by her shirt or whatever
example like it's just everywhere that's
the thing it's it's insidious it's
everywhere you can find it everywhere
yeah if you've got a program running
it's everywhere you can find a little
two percent over here
over there
so you just need one thread it's like
continue finding my laugh just like tell
me about your laugh and that he didn't
even know like he didn't know where that
was going to go where it was going to go
yeah but it's just like something's off
here like something's for yourself here
you've got you've got a little thread of
this agenda and if we just trace it back
it's going to unravel the whole shirt
yeah
so go on the offense
oh my gosh
and it's so much more liberating when
you don't come into a room
um like wanting to
uh get or extract or to be seen or to be
the one that makes some sort of a
liberation happen um
that's so cute
are you seeing his gods right now
how could i how could i help liberate
you
i don't know i'm just igniting global
awakening over here guys
we
just so everybody knows we've been
um
having so much fun with atlas's
um alice's thing do you care if we get
into this yeah we can so your thing has
been getting into um
it's yeah i love that you already sort
of called it out like being the one who
liberates being the one who enlightens
so but one of our favorite access points
with you has been your jargon it's been
such a giveaway
it's such a cool one it's like so so the
equivalent of my my laugh like cackling
somewhere with oh nice it's just like
it's like here's a giveaway there's
something we don't know where we're
gonna go with this but there's something
there yeah with all the like with any
pattern basically anything where it's
like oh that's such an atlas thing to do
or that's such a core thing to do if you
can find that if you can find something
that's like
damn i could have predicted that yep
you there the access point yes start
there yeah
yeah and you've been you've just made
leaps
yeah thanks to
this container is so good it's awesome
yeah
even quick
quick work
yeah the growth mindset like wanting
wanting it yeah wanting more than like
reaching out with both hands for the
opportunity yeah
i remember too back before you joined us
we had
we had a conversation about the kedaz or
about nls or something and do you
remember this i was in mexico we were on
zoom
and i think and i said something about
your
you having some sort of agenda are you
having you trying to get something
and you're like whoa whoa whoa whoa like
your first response was like hold up
whoa that's a little strong
um i'll give you this but i'm not gonna
it was like bless your heart and like
now now to see you like with no defense
anymore yeah
like really just like taking the full
hit and being like
wow holy [ __ ] i see it thank you like
with follow-up questions and yes yes yes
such a transformation there nice yeah
wow do you remember do you remember that
i feel like that does ring a bell yeah
yeah i just remember you specifically
being like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
yeah like literally defense yeah this is
so defense yeah
whoa
i'll give you this
oh
yeah and to juxtapose that with what um
you share which is sort of like when
someone does approach you from the team
like you just want to know right away
like what is it yeah um tell me like
what's the reflection that i need right
now like really it's almost like thank
you let's let me
could it be this like i'm helping them
i'm
giving them data i'm volunteering it
like let's [ __ ] find it but
i'm not going to take any time defending
like
we're going after that hijacker yeah
nice
fun
cool so
so we could say that
the
formation
uh let's say yeah location a separation
and then how that just blossoms into all
these corlac beliefs and stuff like that
um
that
that you could call that the gremlin or
you could call that the hitchhiker you
could call that the
um what is constantly being reflected
to
liberate yourself from
to deconstruct
so the gremlin or the hitchhiker
is what's being reflected
which is not you
and that's the deconstruction project
nice
and you can see like that example you
gave of me
a couple months ago
is
like six seven now months ago
that
that's more of that gremlin or
hitchhiker energy that is defending
um
well it's you teaming up with the
hitchhiker it's me yeah yeah it's
it's it's yeah it's like i am this so if
you're coming at that you're coming at
me
and i will defend us both
as opposed to you being like uh yeah
sticker from hold up yeah yeah right so
you the in the analogy you could say
that like the
the sticker paper that is white
is i
um capital i capital s self god and then
you have this like sticker
that's on the sticker paper that's sort
of like this like atlas face
um
and it can you know and it has its like
the little like twist in it that's all
of the different conditioning and
separation ego structure that's been
built up
and to peel away that the gremlin-ness
or the hitchhiker-ness from
i from self from god
to let atlas be pure in its expression
and not in its
so get that little sticker paper or
another analogy i've been to recently
used was the tree and the vines which
was another really good one
so this treeness
um is i self god and then this vineyness
is
um the hitchhiker the ego the gremlin um
and
it's just it all it is is just an
increase in awareness
of
when you're expressing yourself from a
place of vineyness or stickeriness
versus when you express yourself from a
place of sticker paper or treeness
and then just like shifting
the shift yeah nice it's just shifting
the shift and shifting
because it is both nice realization
conviction but it's also
um ongoing purification exactly yeah
yeah both
simultaneously both
yeah and i think like the shift if we
were to say there is a shift that can be
made
um
it's just
reallocating what you identify with like
when you say i what do you mean
like if people could see that when i say
i i mean cory and this
body and the clothes that i wear in my
history and my personality and my sense
of how things should be and so if i'm
calling all of that corey or i if i'm
calling all of that i that's the stuff
that if that gets threatened or poked at
or
then i get offended or i get triggered
or i get upset or it feels threatening
but if i
am the one that is aware of all that
or capital i white paper
if that's actually what i believe i am
and that i
that is real for me that it's not just
like yeah
yeah i am i am god ultimately i know
that i am the one infinite creator no i
actually have my identity like
when i feel i it's like
the one who knows the one who is aware
the one who can opt for
these different variables in my life but
those are not me
so if if it's the one who has choice the
one who knows then this stuff can get
poked at and it's like oh interesting
really like there's no there's no
texture
yeah it's all optional you're right your
identity is not uh
unraveled or intertwined with uh yeah
with the um
psychology or conditioning with the
objects yeah so the subject is not
intertwined with the object nice yeah so
that would be the shift if we were gonna
say
make like a shift of peeling the sticker
off the paper it's to reallocate your
identity onto what i actually is sweet
yeah
sweet sweet and yeah that makes it so
much easier than to get to the onion
layers because it's not you then um yeah
and then that you then treat it like
like you said it's like a fun
um deconstruction project like it's a
yeah
it's a
a simulation of constructing of
psychology and then a deconstructing of
it totally like our own little
personalized uh like realization room or
escape room if you will um
and that makes it really like cute and
fun and playful and it's just
way different than when it's heavy and
dense and i've gotten reflected that
several times two is uh turning it into
a dense thing nice it's so bad it's it's
surprising with you because you are so
sort of silly and yeah and open and
light and but yeah when it comes to some
of these processes where you are still
identified yeah it it you do you have
sort of a dense reaction to it but it's
another thing with you it's just a
giveaway it's like nice it's such a we
found one yeah here we go
what's wrong yeah
oh my gosh
that's so good
and so then
um yeah anytime you're
like still
um
yeah like feeling a denseness in
your um
in like the unraveling or unwinding of
of your conditioning um
to
to like let go of that
just let go of it like go of the densest
and notice that the denseness is just
coming from a place of wanting to be
seen
almost always it's just coming from
wanting to be validated or seen
look at me and what process i'm going
through um
and
yeah that or i think
also very common is to be just to feel
safe
so for a lot of people it's for you i
think it's a be seen thing for me to be
a same thing but for a lot of people
it's actually to like
protect
be almost be unseen
like to be just to be safe to be not
exposed to
kind of cocoon
denseness yeah kind of cocoon yeah it's
just serious it's like serious gravity
like
just
like
sort of take themself off the map
oh so to retreat
yeah or to be or just to make things
sort of serious and significant and and
it's not yeah i have people in mind that
i don't want to um
don't want to get into that but like
where so
you'll see this you'll give someone a
reflection who's normally upbeat and
like and suddenly it's just like
oh
and it's like this it's like suddenly
like super like oh you don't want to go
there we don't want to oh it's just like
the seriousness where it's just like i
uh it's to be not seen
oh it's to not be exposed it's to sort
of like is it the acting that we were
talking about a little bit like a little
bit of an acting defense mechanism it's
definitely a defense mechanism yeah yeah
okay
yeah it's all a defense mechanism for
sure yeah
just different ones but cool go ahead
okay
sweet
um
yeah let's
what are we at okay let's talk a little
bit more um
another word that i think um is helpful
here is honor
that's been
uh there's the honor retreat where
bentino and anurag really unpack what uh
they feel uh honor is and also for for
those that were attending to just
realize themselves um directly what it
is um to me i defined it as just pure
service
is how i defined it um
and
so like honor would be like
only seeing the whole and only coming
from wanting to serve the whole like
awakening to itself
um and
and the word purity there is really
important because then you're not doing
it from again from a place of wanting to
be seen or whatnot but you're just doing
it to serve the whole
so
so honor playing into this process that
we've been talking about with the
construction project honors
you could say
the
the active participation in the
deconstruction project from a place
that's empty of self-interest
cool
do you do you feel resonant with that i
think so can you say it again so honor
is what
motivates you basically to do the
deconstruction process
yeah to to serve
others in their deconstruction projects
while you're empty of self-interest in
that process
is honor is yeah it could be a way to
view honor
showing up on the soccer field to play
the game which is the deconstruction
project but empty of self-interest only
to win the game together as a whole
okay um the deconstruction project now
feels
too limiting to say that's what honor is
to say that honestly oh cool um
because not necessarily probably usually
but and i liked in the honor retreat
honorary and ben actually
um
declined like they decided not to define
honor
because if you're
if you define it you can
you can find loopholes you can it
becomes something that you can sort of
just like
qualify for yourself and like here is
honor
and i am acting with honor if x y z
and
it's just like you have but honor
actually it's um
it's a living barometer
for
i would say i liked your first
definition how
pure service yeah piercer like if like
how constituted you are in service
to others or service to tool
and um
yeah
and for sure
that motivates doing the deconstruction
project yeah for sure i love that so
deconstruction project is actually only
um a component right of so how
constituted you are in service to others
or the all
right that's great i mean i love that
that's great
but i like what i like is to not defend
i do that stuck with me like cool tune
into it afresh every single time like
what is honor now and what is on and out
and what is honor now and what if you
reach six density and there's some new
angle on service
and suddenly it's not about service to
all their service to others and like who
knows so how would honor reply then
yeah
so i like honor as a living thing that
you just tune into and you can it's just
it has this like i love that you know
refresh rate on yes yeah nice just like
infinity or god yes you just there's no
way to put any you can't attach anything
to that right it just you can't same
thing with honor i love that yeah me too
great and i have a similar feeling with
purity
like purity is just like what is pure
actually and not to be and not to call
it like
empty of ego or not none of that like
just what is purity just tune into it
from scratch and get that
the innocence of it get the like
wow that's great
it's so good and then to
yeah um i like in super accelerated
living
which is one of the
books spentino wrote
that
the focus on like the refresh rate and
like your presence
constantly
being generated by your preference like
you constantly just choose
what you want to radiate and like you
think in future presence and not like
now
because now is just the past
thoughts that led to now but like i'm
just literally thinking like before this
podcast i was thinking about us like
high-fiving like [ __ ] yeah great podcast
like other people being like dude that
was a great conversation that helped me
in this way or that way i talked to my
friend about it blah blah blah
living like that nice
so
you wake up and now like every day is
like future presence it's like all
future presence like i'm thinking about
the meetings we have later and those
going really well that's great and
things like that and then
um
and then same thing with like honor or
purity or god or infinity is that
there's no um
there's no way it's so fresh
it's to treat it that fresh
is
it's so liberating because nothing ever
gets fixated or like grasped onto in the
i used to be like that and you guys saw
that a lot like in my first especially a
couple months here said i and the whole
thing she brought up about jargon that
corey brought up
oh my gosh so like you like to not get
fixated on jargon and to not get
conceptual
i see what you're yeah it's because you
can hook on to you heard me i was saying
c as god sees so much like that should
be the [ __ ] gym model the the the
uh
yeah
and so to like let go of any
fixation on um symbology um and to keep
a refresh rate because then it's like
constantly coming from the spaciousness
um and availability to serve in whatever
way shows up and then you could say that
that is that honor or whatever nice
yeah perfect
nice nice throwback to um super
accelerated living too
yeah
so powerful
we'll have a video deploying on the
channel soon where um ben reads the top
quotes of super accelerated living
awesome and also spiritual conversations
that's awesome
exactly that's so good and then we'll be
promoting those books that way because
they're both such timeless masterpieces
it's so good to get them out yeah
yeah timeless is right as you were
replying or um
reiterating the super accelerated living
it's like damn that stuff never gets old
yeah it's been years but it's all about
the state change to what ben says in
there yeah because the thing is you re
you open the book and then you go back
to normal atlas
you can't do that like the whole point
is for you to change like your presence
and change that those habits like to
just be future present and to just
constantly be pasting oneness onto
everything over and over and over again
um
so you but to like treat it that way
like that's one of the
best things about um like
self-development and whatnot is to like
take those habit changers the patterns
of the way you express yourself
seriously and um playfully but then do
it
like and like take them all the way like
people stop so quick with us it's like a
two-week practice but man those things
are so powerful actually yeah yeah i
still use i still use that stuff it's
every time like even just this one
future presence i love that so good
so good yeah love it
yeah such a good way to put it
i even feel like um
yeah i should read i should read one of
them do it um it's so good
oh my god i love these clothes
um
okay
yeah here
place everything you desire in your past
a little while ago and feel what that
was like
and then and then this one to be in the
future generates more presence than to
be in the present which is based on the
past
so good such gold
yep
to be all in means that your only
priority is to always manage your state
of being
oh god that's so cool
so timeless yeah quotes so good
like your only priority is to manage
your state of being this is full circle
to what we were talking about before
like
like being in inside of the heat like
being sort of
closer and closer and closer to the core
and like leading by example is
having that like second to second micro
second to or millisecond to millisecond
awareness of just like where am i coming
from like just to be on
point with your vibration with your
state of being that's really the work
like that at first it's gross and you're
like first it's just you're it's you're
getting seeds planted and take it or
leave it and then it gets like
intense and chaotic and
stuff is getting purged and then
you get this
this layer of
accountability and honor and purity and
like
i am 100 responsible for managing my
vibration now and now and now and now
and tracking it and being
and being accountable for it like
if something's off i'm handling that now
now this is one this is top priority
this is urgent
yeah
cool what a good full circle
because that's what it was like seven
months ago or whatever hey at least take
it or leave it
and then it's like here in august it's
like there's no taking it yeah you will
take it
or leave
yeah
[Laughter]
and then it's
manage your vibrational state always
vibrational attitude is what it was
called
yeah
so it's like yeah managing your
vibrational attitude moment to moment um
your accountability yeah for that yeah
so cool yeah which i think it's been
cool to see you like having fielded some
intense reflections some real like
peel that sticker paper off the
peel the sticker off the sticker paper
reflections
and for you to get that context of like
oh that's where i was coming from and
now
to see that you are
accountable for that like you are like
oh
oh i might have been positioning myself
and like to call it out now and now and
now now because it's not like that stuff
just goes away when you see it
immediately it's like oh i'm doing it
i'm doing it again
nice
yeah yeah
and that's what makes you
reliable like that i mean it's not that
you never have any yeah triggers or you
never have any of your stuff come up but
it's that you
you call it out and you are like guards
down like oops yep yep yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah even we just had a session a
couple uh nights ago with the team just
talking and i could tell that like the
quality of my expression went from
something that was like really pure in
service of the whole and then after a
couple more shares it like went to i
just literally said this to be seen and
i like caught myself yeah and i was just
like damn it like okay
now i see that what what happened it was
just a slip and awareness
really it's just just
it's just a slip and awareness like at
the end it's just like
you get too caught up in the fixation of
i'm going to say this right now
so good now you're in the work like when
i see that it's like now you're doing it
now you have
you you can like
you can this is a private process now
like you now you're sort of beyond the
need of like
the intervention or the call out or the
like
the harsh reflection like you're beyond
that like now you can just
you know that's a cool i i didn't
realize it until this conversation but
there is like that's you get to this
harmony or this
sort of flowiness where you your walls
are down like your your guard is down
and
so stuff can just come up and you can be
like and it's light and it's
and you want to see it and you're not
sort of actively defending it you're not
offendable you're not
it's not that same sort of um
yeah i think i think that offendable
like the fact that you have to like go
through that phase of
like purging all your triggers is what
intimidates people the most about
spirituality or about this work like
having like i'm gonna have to get called
out and get offended and get you know
have all my stuff be seen in front of
people and
but then after you cross that and see
what it really is and that it's just
about letting the guard down just like
putting my cards down and just being
like damn i am i'm sabotaging this
meeting right now i'm
manipulating just to
get a leg up in this conversation right
now and like this just putting your
cards down and seeing it that's all it
takes
that's it and it feels good and you feel
connected
and
it's like it's i mean if that if people
could see that
it's not this
life-threatening
purge
it's actually this relief that we've all
been nice
wanting cool i think we'd have more more
staying power in the community
yeah
awesome good job yeah you did so good
yeah yeah you too such a such a good
convo i love that bit on relief yeah
because it's just the relief from
separation
totally it's so
there's nothing
better yeah
such a good convo cory thank you
yeah thanks for joining us on the show
thank you for having me so cool i look
forward to
more of these uh convos and especially
like with no limit society blossoming in
the way that it is we can sort of
leverage um
the platform of uh communicating on the
the web and through video to our
audience as well as to
um
just hit a hundred thousand subscribers
on youtube very [ __ ] huge very cool
huge love it yep and so we can keep uh
sharing these types of dialogues to
um
to our audience and then also to um
inspire people to check out no limit
society sort of we can update people
about like what's happening here like
these things that we were talking about
with the cadet guides like this type of
things it's really cool
and do that um so the link in the bio
will be to no limit society also to um
corey's instagram is probably a good
place to follow corey sure yeah yep so
we'll have cory's instagram link down
there
and
um we'll put super accelerated living as
well in spiritual conversation with a
skeptic down there um
also ben's youtube channel we'll put
down there
any other thoughts or
links that we should put
i don't think so it was pretty good
yeah nice first pod
[Laughter]
so good all right thanks everyone for
tuning in we love you
thank you thanks guys thank you
drop us a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode we'd love to
hear from you
and like the video helps algorithm
subscribe if you have into the channel
and yeah uh share the video also with
people that you feel like this would
resonate with let's get the word out
that purification vibe
all right much love everyone thank you
mwah
see you soon later